[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
while I'm very excited to introduce our
next guest who has been the soundtrack
to our nights out for the past three
decades you know remember when we used
to go out to festivals clubs remember
that
well he's now the soundtrack to our
kitchen discos he is superstar DJ Fat
Boy slim and he is promising the party
to end all parties for NHS staff when
this crisis is over
Norman cook is on lockdown in Brighton
and joins us now nan how are you I'm
good how you doing yeah really good
actually keeping positive it's a bit of
an odd time at the moment isn't it it's
a very strange time it's I mean is it
wrong to say that sometimes I'm almost
excited by it we're going through
something I did that that word
unprecedented has been way overused but
nice it's something you kind of feel
like we're making history here which
which is a good it's a good way of
spinning it so it feels like you know
we've got to get through this you know
our parents might went through the Blitz
and and this is kind of our blitz so I
see yeah occasionally I do find some
excitement in having to make do and the
way we have to live our lives has not
been treated you because you lived a
jet-set lifestyle
until this coronavirus hit traveling the
world doing huge gigs and I'm just
wondering how you're finding a slightly
slower pace of life it's treating me
fairly so far I'm lucky that I live on
the beach so we've got fresh air and
feel like we've got some sense of space
and I am locked down with people that I
love very dearly so that helps it's I
mean it's weird for me my obviously my
job involves the whatever the polar
opposite of social distancing is so that
was the first casualty and I cut before
we'd even lock down I'd obviously I'd
already got my head around the fact that
I probably wouldn't be working much this
summer which is yeah which again it's
it's just for those things you have to
deal with yes interesting is it
they said your job is bringing people
together you know crowded dance floors
big gigs and I know you've spoke in the
past about the community you find on a
dance floor you know it doesn't matter
where you come from you know what you
think about things music is the great
leveler and when you all love the same
tune you're all in it together yes I
mean there's a tremendous sense of
community that comes through being
together listening to music and losing
yourself in a night out but there's also
a power of music to have a sense of
community for the new community that
they sort of online community that we're
living through so we found other ways of
using what I do to bring people together
or give them just giving a sense of less
isolation the fact that you know
everybody's going through the same thing
and they're all still in there in their
kitchen trying to get excited on a
Friday night too so I don't know I mean
my my in desperate times like this you
kind of view look to a sense of the
community of what can I contribute to it
and obviously my skills of my skill set
is fairly limited in terms of what real
good I can do for the for the country or
for for Humanity but suppose cheering
people up through music or making them
feel connected through music it's the
one thing I can do yeah talk to me about
this free party you're putting on for
NHS workers and their partners as well I
noticed that you like you know they
partners support them in what they're
doing so they deserves a big night out
as well it was just a friend of mine who
works at the NHS said oh would you mind
just doing a little little viral for the
NHS work is just it's give them support
or thanks or this is quite early on so I
made a little er I made a little film
hello this is a message from Fat Boy
slim to all the doctors all the nurses
all the key workers and at the end of it
I sort of half jokingly said and when
all this is over we should have a big
party together and you know when we can
and so many people hast certainly took
me up on that and everybody I'm bump
into the supermarket goes brinjal party
having then and so I just thought it's
the one thing that I can be thinking
about and planning and doing and so we
a book tonight at the Brighton Center
and we just yet and I just thought I'd
invite all the NHS workers and the blue
light workers anyone on the front line
really to come and you know shake off
the cobwebs when all this is over yeah
and they're certainly looking forward to
that tickets sold out in three minutes
and no I don't know if you know any
medics personally but boy did they know
how to party I was at Union with quite a
few they know how to let her hair down I
was actually married to a nurse I'm
point in my life so yeah I'm aware of it
yes no I know but also I mean more
importantly um it's just it's some way
of saying thank you for me and be just
giving people something to look forward
to I actually had a really a strange
moment on Friday night when when the
tickets went out and because they
literally just went online and they just
went in that second and a friend of mine
got a call from some people who are
actually in the ICU saying we couldn't
get the tickets because we were on duty
no can we get some food kind of through
the back door and they and so I said
give me their phone number so I I
facetimed them while they're on duty in
full PPE on the ward and for me that
really brought it home just they were so
excited even though they could hardly
hear me because the phone even the phone
had to be in a plastic bag so it was all
quite muffled but just to literally talk
to the frontline felt that I was
connected in some way with the great job
they're doing the NHS all of us at some
point in our lives have an experience of
the NHS and I just wonder if it has a
special resonance with you every
Thursday night we turn up to to clap for
carers you've obviously given them this
free party this feel-good experience
what does the NHS mean to you norm what
a few things I mean my father is in an
intensive care unit for 10 days couple
years ago and so I've spent a lot of
time in there seeing what they do so you
know I've been touched in that way
avoiding politics I've you know I've
always been a big fan of the NHS and
always been trying to be as vocal as
possible in helping the government to
understand how much
we should be looking after the NHS and
you know basically financially so I mean
I want you know if you're looking for
good news the good news is that an awful
lot of politicians who maybe didn't
think the NHS was that important now
realize how important it can be in our
lives some of them very very directly
obviously you talked about your summer
changing this year it'd be first season
canceled Glastonbury cancelled and this
party that you're throwing for NHS staff
won't be until October when do you think
we'll be gigging in the same way again
in terms of like you said what you do is
all about bringing people together and
it's gonna take a while for that to come
back isn't it naturally mmm I mean
obviously nobody knows but one thing I'm
pretty much sure of is that the the
shutters will come up very slowly and in
increments and I'm kind of figuring that
what I do is gonna be one of the last
things that's that's that's allowed
again in this appropriate again so there
you know so many other parts of our
lives will open up first and like I said
you know bringing tons of sweaty people
together in a very confined space he's
probably the most irresponsible thing so
it would be the last thing to come back
which just will make us cherish it even
more when that moment I mean the sad
thing is that they won't be that that
sort of VE Day moment oh you girl go and
dance in the streets because it will
happen so gradually probably over six
months I love the thought and will be
the last the last I think I mean I could
see myself probably if there's a limit
of like 500 people I should just be just
firing up every club that's got a fire
limit of 490 it's a bar line you know
there's a few there's a few venues in
Brighton that I've got of understanding
with at the minute that they're allowed
to we're just gonna put the party you
know whatever that whatever level we can
but I think I think you know the the the
big international festivals are probably
the worst thing we could be doing right
now because people are travelling from
all over the world and then we're
putting them all squash team all
together in a very big unseemly pile so
I'm not really I mean at the moment I'm
looking at
half my summer has been canceled so far
and this you know things like this as
time speaking camp bestival is still on
but I haven't really got my hopes on
anything large happening this summer
what we know you enjoy the intimate gigs
as well so that would be good to ease
you back into it and also I don't know
if you've seen that picture doing the
rounds on social media norm of the first
plane out to Ibiza what eventually
people are allowed to return it is
literally people hanging off the wings
and hanging out the windows desperate to
get back out there and just you know
have that feel-good factor again yeah I
mean there is plenty to feel good over
in the meantime I know I thought I think
what camp best of all did over the
Easter weekend was great especially for
for us parents so to get our kids sort
of somehow just I know just getting a
virtual feeling of letting your hair
down and relaxing and celebrating rather
than morning
oh yeah the kitchen disco is big right
now in lockdown it's big in my household
I know it's big in yours and because
like every good parent you're taking
your homeschooling very seriously but
different there you've got a DJ school
going a 10 year old Nelly your daughter
she gets top marks because this was her
performance the other week hi my name is
Nelly Cooke and from now on also known
as fat girl
[Music]
and so how did this all come about norm
it seems like music very much is the
family trade well ladies kind of been
sort of watching me DJ all her life and
thinking how hard can it be
mmm she so she's been kind of learning
with me and then in the midst of all I
do every Friday night I do a look down
mix our four kitchen neighbors but I've
held off from doing the actual kind of
home gigs because watching a DJ without
an audience is kind of like watching
paint dry for me but then camp bestival
wanted to do a thing that got all the
kids up and they were doing a big sleep
out sleeping ngons pretend you're a
festival and they asked all the people
who are going to be appearing camp best
of all to contribute something and then
I was just because I was talking to my
daughter Nellie and Camp best of all
this summer was going to be her first
ever festival and she's gonna be so
disappointed if it doesn't happen and so
I just thought it was a way of getting
her involved in Camp best of all and I
don't know I just I just thought what if
I get Nellie today and I'd help and
would that be any good I mean I didn't
really didn't know if he was gonna be
any good at it and I feel it's gonna be
enjoyable for other people if it's a bit
self-indulgent but it was it was fun for
me and Lily to do to set it all up and
do it work out a little set for her and
but it really caught the public's
imagination yeah it's gonna be
interesting to see who gets more
bookings when we come out of this on the
other side cos boy oh boy that was one
great debut set fabulous I mean she I
was sorry she just stepped up through it
like should be doing all her life yes
she had a marriage proposal she's got
various gig bookings I mean that's she's
had five million streams
and I thought the other day five million
people that's probably more than I've
ever deejay to my whole career
traveling and late nights and just she
just strolls into those five million
them on the first guy but now I'm very
very proud of that and just I just felt
that is me using my talents to keep the
emotions
morale buoyant in the best of my
capabilities I I don't know some some
things seem a little trivial time on
this and I mean for a while I thought
mean what I did was you know
if it looked like everybody was doing
you know DJing from their bedroom last
night a point like this people don't
really want to watch you DJ in your
bedroom they've got bigger fish to fry
they've got kids to look after yes
well norm it's been so good to talk to
you I know you've got a pop quiz later
on
and my producer did say norm might be a
four or five minutes late for this chat
because he's having a shave so for those
who are watching on the video version of
this on YouTube you should be honored
those listening to the podcast so you'll
be disappointed but now I know it's for
the pop quiz later on norm I don't know
about you see probably you you're still
in the public eye so you don't let
yourself go but certain standards I
thought there's an audio podcast I think
I'd know you're not alone when I found
out we were doing a video version of
this podcast I was very disappointed
nice goodies kitchen on your toes but my
favorite quote from all of this is my
mum who self thought she's quite old and
frail so she's self isolated weeks
before the lockdown and every time I say
- how you getting on she said well I've
got the garden you know she's got my
husband and she said she said he's quite
nice she said I don't have to feel I
feel like I have to make the effort
because I know no one's coming around
norm thank you so much for talking to
his Norman cook aka Fat Boy slim putting
on that party to end all parties for NHS
staff in October it's been great to chat
and stay safe that's what you do to stay
safe say stain ha ha
[Music]
you